for decades Howard Schultz was held as
an example of benign U.S capitalism his
company was the first to offer ownership
equity in a strong benefits package and
now it says it offers a minimum wage of
over 17 an hour among the highest in the
country
the committee chair though sees another
picture over the past 18 months
Starbucks has waged the most aggressive
and illegal Union bustling campaign in
the modern history of our country
that Union bustling campaign has been
led by Howard Schultz
Starbucks has become the focus of
intense criticism by labor groups for
allegedly trying to crush attempts by
individual stores to unionize every day
we wake up thinking about how we can put
our people first put them in a position
to win
and do everything we can to demonstrate
the conscience the heart and the values
of Starbucks Coffee Company great and
there was support from a number of
committee members don't derive one of
the Great American sex success stories I
don't want to be part of any Witch Hunt
that vilifies any American Business
the committee also heard from some of
the more than 80 people who say they've
been fired from Starbucks for Union
Activity thank you chairman Sanders
among them Jason Saxton a former Union
organizer at a Starbucks in Georgia
who testified he was fired in a phone
call two hours before the beginning of
his shift for what was described as
disruptive behavior
before the hearing he told me that far
from being disruptive his Union work was
intended to better the futures of his
co-workers and his two-year-old daughter
Ava because otherwise
she's going to have to continue to see
Mom and Dad
struggling and unhappy and stressed the
quote unquote American dream is just
hustle culture at this point
and I don't want my daughter to have to
deal with that
and a number of Republicans on the
committee sharply attacked the National
Labor Relations Board claiming it
displayed a strongly anti-corporate bias
in a bid to Ghana Union support for the
Biden Administration
are nlrb employees weaponizing the
agency against American employers and
while that debate rages the reality is
that dozens like Jason Sexton and his
family are paying the price of what they
regard as corporate greed
Mike Hannah oh Jazeera Washington
Kathy Creighton is director of Cornell
University School of industrial and
Labor Relations she says that a
unionized Workforce is more productive
and safer for the employees
workers generally want to have and this
is particularly with the Starbucks
workers they want to have a say
um in their Workforce they don't want to
be uh told what to do by a benevolent
dictator as Howard Schultz apparently
thinks that he is and I think the that
what the American public should know is
that the a unionized Workforce is really
a much better Workforce not just for the
workers and for the employer also and
particularly beneficial in the Civil
Society so where there's a unionized
Workforce we have a more Equitable
Workforce where people of color do much
better up to 20 percent better than
their non-union peers where the gender
gap is cut in half in a unionized
Workforce where there's higher
productivity higher retention rates a
safer workplace a happier workplace and
then there's all these Myriad of things
that Ripple out from that so that
unionized workers generally give more to
charity they have increased voter
turnout they volunteer in their
communities more often so there's lots
of reasons for America to want to have a
unionized Workforce where employees
simply have a say in their workplace and
that was not acknowledged by Starbucks
at all